hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to in Lucy's eyes now I
wouldn't be in such a bad situation with
all my matches if I had not been
wandering around for hours and hours
Classic Accessories I was wandering
around for like 20 minutes
but I was wandering around for what
seemed like hours and hours and nothing
was happening I had no idea what I was
doing but unfortunately I'm now out of
matches and it's very very dork dork
there's no light except there is a light
over here it's an ominous red glowing
light but I'll take anything at this
point so I hope I'm going the right way
it really it really was not very very
well presented on what I was supposed to
do there just because of the problem of
there being such a tiny tiny amount of
light available and this isn't even
where I was supposed to go this is just
a hindi hole okay but either way I think
I'm getting close to the end of this
because like obviously the loading
screen note said I was almost there and
I haven't had a loading screen in a
while so I'm just under the assumption
that I might just be getting a little
close if I only I could see where I was
going
sassa main premiere because it's all
done by matches I have to using such
short bursts but if I do need to use
them in short bursts and I'm not going
the right way then what the hell am I
supposed to do with my life
I'm not going the right way am i what am
I supposed to do with my life damn it
okay did I oh no see this is exactly
what I mean it seemed like I was
supposed to go through here because it
was the only way to go that was forward
did I not go a right way oh I didn't I'm
such a dingus I'm such a dingus I just
wear
I was rather intense someone's not happy
with me being a dingus it's okay I know
I'm actually smart it's just for a joke
don't worry about it hey I have pretty
high self esteem you stay cool you
rumbly roar you you whale noise okay I
didn't even need to use that because
it's relatively brighter in here than it
was downstairs I know I love you too oh
you're so sweet I appreciate that I
really do but I gotta get to the bottom
of this I gotta find me Lucy oh that's
bad too because every time you go up a
ladder if you handle a match out I'll
just pull out an extra one great I only
have one match left that does not bode
well for me wait what oh okay this would
give it gimme gimme
all right so please tell me there's more
matches yes there we go three is good
enough for me so Oh is there gonna be
some special bonus secret up here
there's some special bonus secret over
here yes please maybe maybe maybe no of
course not I just wasted a match for no
reason
remember when I had more matches and I
know what to do with that was great time
I love that time made me feel awesome
cause now I feel like I've got nothing
oh okay that wasn't a real ladder that
was a fakie fakie ladder why did I come
up here this is where I was supposed to
be am I supposed to just drop down oh my
ankles they broke into my spleen
oh the sit Oh
the burial chamber David I'm not pretty
David okay write it or she can screaming
your name begging for help
miles I would have been a mother I just
have to be a mother
beautiful
I just walk just like my little baby did
my dreams she's my daughter now David
there's nothing you can do about it okay
apparently I had some misunderstandings
from the get-go of this game I thought I
was someone else I had no idea what was
going on
may I please have my daughter back uh I
don't even know where you are what am I
supposed to be looking for what am i
doing
what's going on put them in what do we
do well I don't know what to do I didn't
even see you what do I need to do what
do i do what do i do what do i do what
do i do oh I know what to do but I don't
know what to do I won't know oh there
you are
I'm coming Lucy
Oh gonna be fine
oh excuse me did you put him away my
math brothers painting what did I do it
how am i doing it did I done it I did it
yeah no one looks very happy about that
but I think I did it
hey I thought that was gonna be more to
that antics oh let's go home
oh I did it I did it I think I don't
know exactly what I did I think I just
charged the creepy lady in her face
punched her and grabbed Lucy and ran I
had no idea even though I was supposed
to look at her over there
I'll see you talking by the giant pillar
of light
wake up Anna it's okay and she's gone
now come with me I want to show you a
very special place of mind
okay right okay I'm confused as hell I
have no idea what that was about I had
like I don't know why was I think I was
distracted because I was so scared in
the beginning in this game that I didn't
even understand why or who I was which
was really bizarre now that I think
about that oh that of course that makes
sense obviously I'm not the psychotic
guy because he didn't have a daughter
therefore I must have been someone else
but I'd even think about that because I
was too busy with everything else
either way this was phenomenal this
might be one of the best and these
accustomed stories I've ever played the
only problem I had with it is that I got
lost a lot just because with the match
mechanic it was very hard to know which
direction I was going and if I did get
lost I wasted more matches all these
guys made tenebrous Lake I loved
tenebrous Lake tenebrous tenebrous
tenebrous Wow I had no idea about that
that's awesome okay so thank you
developers of this game this is a
phenomenal one this is amazing I love
this a lot and it's good to know that
people are still making phenomenal
amnesia custom stories good for you guys
thank you so much for doing it and thank
you everybody for watching this was one
of the longer series that I've done I
mean the parts weren't very long but I
played for a long time being very lost
and stupid but I cut those parts out so
you didn't have to see that you just saw
me after the fact where I was lost in
stupid so either way thank you guys so
much for sticking through the series
thank you so much if you enjoyed it let
me know what you thought in the comments
below sincerely I want to hear and if
you got suggested for more scary games
awesome games silly games any type of
games let me know in the comments as
well thanks again everybody check out
the amazingly huge list of amnesia
custom stories that I've done the past
in the description below and thanks
and as always I will see you in the next
one bye sure you want his gun one does
make a lot of fun
yeah
what
Oh